The Joe Rogan experience.
The second thing is I believe that there are no,
I say this in my ceremony,
there's no such thing as sacred cow or sacred plants are sacred.
Mountains are sacred people.
If we don't treat life with sacredness,
but if we recognize that everything is sacred,
then we infuse life with sacredness and meaning and that's,
anyway,
that's why I do,
it's a lot of fun.
That's very interesting from a guy who specializes essentially in manipulating
life.
Well,
you know we have manipulated life as humans for a very short on time,
but that's interesting.
You know the idea of things being sacred,
but your specialty is manipulating genetics,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
so that is this strange moment that we're in because for about for about 3.8
billion years,
our species has evolved by this set of principles we call Darwinian evolution,
random mutation and natural selection.
It's brought us here.
We used to be single cell organisms and now look at us and there's been a lot of
magic in that process and there still is,
but we humans are decipher some of that magic.
We are like looking under the hood of what it means to be human.
And we are increasingly going to have the ability to manipulate all of life,
including our own.
Yeah.
That is very unnerving to a lot of people.
It's,
it's,
it's uncomfortable and scary and yeah,
it is.
They like things the way they are.
We only,
I'd like to stay the way I am.
We always think that there's the,
we always think that there's a built in conservative conservatism in our brains.
Um,
and yet we live these lives that are entirely dependent on these radical changes
that our ancestors have created.
I mean,
we didn't find this building or agriculture medicine,
uh,
in nature.
We built all those things and then everybody gets a new baseline when you're
born and you think,
well,
you know,
I'm,
I want,
you know,
organic corn,
I want whatever.
But all these things are creation.
We live in entirely created world and our ability to manipulate and change that
world is always growing.
And I think we need to recognize that,
but there's being afraid is okay and being excited as okay.
And we need to find the right balance between those two emotions.
I think for a lot of people,
they feel like so many changes happen,
particularly when you're talking about genetically modified foods.
So many things happened before they realize they had happened.
So when they're like,
hey man,
I don't want anything to eat any GMO fruit.
Well then you probably shouldn't eat any fruit.
Yup.
Because everything that you buy has been changed.
Like every orange that you buy that.
That's why when an orange,
just to be like,
yeah,
could buy an apple,
Apple's didn't used to be like that.
Tomatoes didn't used to be like that.
No,
I know.
That's we,
we reset our baseline just from when we're kids.
So if you went back 12,000 years ago to the end of the last ice age,
and you said,
all right,
find me all these things that we buy at whole foods.
Most of them didn't exist.
We,
we've created them.
Sure.
And then in the 1970s we had the ability to do what's recombinant DNA when
people call the genetic modification and people are afraid because it's,
well,
that feels unnatural.
We're applying science to,
to food.
Um,
and you know,
that's,
that's the issue and now we're,
we're entering the era of genetically modified humans and there's that same
level of uncomfortableness.
But what happened,
the reason why I've written this,
uh,
this book hacking Darwin,
is that if we approached genetically modified humans in the same way that we
approached Niggli modified foods,
which is the scientists say,
Hey,
we've got this,
we're going to manage them responsibly.
And it just kind of happens to people.
People are gonna go nuts.
I mean,
you imagine how agitated people are about GMO foods.
If they don't have a say in how the genetic,
the experience,
the human experience of genetic modification plays out,
people are going to go berserk.
So we have this window of time,
we can start bringing everybody into an inclusive conversation about where we're
going because where we are going is just radically different from where we've
been.
Yeah.
I think it's an awareness issue and I also think it's a perception issue.
I think that everything people do is natural.
Yeah.
Including cities.
I think cities are natural.
That's why they're all over the world.
Yeah.
I think there was naturals beehives and I think as much as we like to think that
technology is not natural,
it's clearly something people naturally make.
Of course they make it in every culture they can.
It's the history of our species and we,
we kind of misuse this word natural trunk.
Give me,
cause what is natural?
I mean maybe natural was when we used to live and we were just part of,
of nature.
And I always say it's like people say,
oh I love nature.
I love like going out and hiking in the woods.
The reason you love hiking in the woods is the,
we've murdered all the predators.
It's like in the old days,
in the year you stay,
in your case,
if you're not going out and hiking in the woods,
there's,
there's stuff that's going to kill you out there.
I know that was a massive luxury to go wander through the forest with no
weapons.
Yeah.
Nobody did that.
Exactly.
But he goes,
oh,
I want nature.
I want my,
you know,
my natural corn.
I want my,
my natural Chihuahua.
Even though,
you know,
25,000 years ago there was no chihuahuas.
There's wolves.
Yeah.
And look what we've done to them,
I know will look what we have done to them.
Made them pugs.
Yeah.
If you had natural wheat like,
or natural corn in particular,
natural,
corny,
submit a tiny little thing.
Yeah.
It's just a few weeds.
Weird gross little grain.
Yep.
And then now we made it this big juicy,
sweet,
delicious thing that you put butter on,
which is great.
But we create,
we can finish that have glyphosate,
glyphosate,
but we,
we can't,
we can't fetishize that.
There's some kind of imaginary world where kind of everybody was wearing
Birkenstocks and eating in wholefoods.
That imaginary world sucked for us.
That's why we left it.
It's true.
But there's some sort of a balance,
right.
We know,
we do appreciate the nature,
uh,
aspect of our world and eagles and salmon and all these wild things and to be
able to see them as very cool.
Yeah.
But yeah,
you don't want to get eaten by those things.
You don't want them everywhere and you,
you,
you want to be able to go out and get your newspaper without being worried about
getting attacked by a Jaguar.